Nicholas sturgeon be suspended or should
she take that decision herself given
that's what Alex salmon did all those
years ago should she now do the
honorable thing and just step back while
this all goes on look ultimately that's
a decision for the SNP it's not for me
to make that decision for them but I
think if you look at previous examples
in the SMP people have been suspended or
people have stepped back and the
question is for example Yusuf is he
strong enough to take the action or is
he too weak to take that previous action
but actually I'm more interested in what
it means for The Wider country and what
it means for how they operate in
government this is a political party
that is famed now for a culture of
secrecy and cover-up in government and
that has had devastating consequences
it's now an incompetent and
dysfunctional SNP government and that's
why we need fundamental change